welcome to Hannity buckle up busy news
night tonight tonight the Democratic
Party they are on the verge of an
all-out Civil War Nancy Pelosi has lost
complete control of her radical
socialist base freshman congresswoman
Acacio Cortez congresswoman to leave in
omar and Ayana
presley are now running the show speaker
Pelosi is now totally powerless I don't
know why she even has the gavel
President Trump has weighed in and now
the fake phony moral selective outrage
machine of the left there is in full
gear how did we get here tonight we will
break it all down we have a special
Hannity investigation into these
fanatical leaders of the Democratic
Party
last week the gloves came off between
congresswoman Alexandria Castillo Cortez
and speaker Pelosi the feud then boiled
over during an interview in Acacio
Cortes suggested Nancy Pelosi's a racist
I've been saying she is Nancy Pelosi
speaker and name only and we have been
right all along
a o'seas attack last week came
immediately after Pelosi told the entire
Democratic House caucus to voice their
concerns directly to her face-to-face
not on social media what did Acacio
Cortes do she went straight to social
media so the question is who really has
the power and meanwhile al sees close
friend and colleague congresswoman
Ayanna Presley launched a racial attack
against Pelosi's allies even some in the
Congressional Black Caucus watch this
for all of you that have aspirations of
running for office for whatever lived
experience an identity that you
represent if you are not prepared to
come to that table and so represent that
voice don't come because we don't need
any more Brown faces that don't want to
be a brown voice we don't need black
[Applause]
we don't want to be a bustah voice we
don't need quizzes that don't want to be
a queer voice alright tonight it does
not matter what speaker Pelosi says what
she does the radicals were in charge
anyone who opposes them of course
quickly labeled xenophobic homophobic
Islamophobic racist sexist a bigot and
want dirty air and water the so called
squad of far-left freshmen Congress
women are now using identity politics
even against members of their own party
the end goal is to fundamentally reshape
America that's what the new Green Deal
is always about it's always been about
it's not about climate change it's not
about saving the environment not at all
instead its primary purpose is to move
the economy away from capitalism and
free market opportunity and a society
that that pays off risk and reward
towards socialism where the government
controls the all the means of production
aoc even said it will tell you how to
run your business and as a matter of
fact the chief of staff for Acacio
cortez look at this recently said the
interesting thing about the green new
deal is it wasn't originally a climate
change thing at all I'm right now some
House Democrats they're sounding the
alarm and they are circulating a poll
showing that only 18 percent of key
voters in swing districts have a
favorable view of socialism that same
poll reveals that only 22 percent have a
favorable view of congresswoman Acacio
Cortes and by the way only nine percent
approve of congresswoman Omar still as
we speak the base of the Democratic
Party is so powerful that every 2020
hopeful has adopted their fringe
socialist policies and if they don't
adopt it completely they're trashed by
many of the four and medicare-for-all
taxpayer-funded healthcare for illegal
immigrants oh yeah no restrictions on
abortion at all even during birth or in
some cases after birth and fantasize and
then of course the green New Deal no
more oil no more gas no more combustion
engine eventually we get rid of planes
and cows and by the way everything is
guaranteed universal basic income a job
higher education
in retirement you name it they'll
provide it the list goes on and on and
with each crazy new policy these
candidates are just digging a deeper and
deeper hole for the general election in
2020 and while we can all agree that
this country is not perfect we all agree
that we're not perfect people there are
no perfect people on this earth that we
want our leaders to work towards
improving the lives of all Americans
let's not forget it was this country the
United States of America the single
greatest country on Earth
we paid the price for freedom defeating
fascism Nazism communism Imperial Japan
and we're now leading the war fighting
radical Islamic terrorists and by the
way we have contributed as a society
more to humanity and the advancement of
the human condition we've asked for less
there's no country that has given more
and asked for less than the USA and we
don't need to be fundamentally
transformed and sadly radical Democrats
they believe something very different
take for example congresswoman Omar
former refugee from war-torn of Somalia
congresswoman Omar recently said that
she probably loves this country more
than the people that were born here okay
congresswoman if that's true you have a
pretty strange way of showing it in fact
during those same remarks she accused
America that they're not live we're not
living up to our reputation really thank
you
take a look we export American
exceptionalism the great America the
land of liberty and justice that is you
know if you ask anybody in walking on
the side of the street somewhere in the
middle of the world they will tell you
America the great but we don't live
values here this is not one isolated
comment or more routinely trashes this
country and sometimes resorting to
conspiracy theories as well to do so she
once claimed that American soldiers
slaughtered thousands of Somalis during
the Black Hawk Down crisis the truth the
reality American soldiers were killed
hundreds of militants literally during a
clash with a violent warlord who had
attacked UN peacekeepers and that's not
all
Omar also claimed that the u.s. was to
blame
for the el Shabab terrorist attack
remember in the mall in Kenya and she
said that us bullying not socialism
led to the devastation in Venezuela she
also called former President Obama even
a pretty face who got away with murder
because of his use of drones and today
she even accused President Trump of
causing the deaths of millions of
Americans oh how did he do that just add
it to the list of why people
psychotically impulsively hate Donald
Trump for no particular reality reason
in reality or rooted in reality take a
look this is a president who has
overseen the most blocked administration
in our history and pursued an agenda to
allow millions of Americans to die from
a lack of health care while he transfers
millions of dollars in tax cuts to
corporations also as you know
congresswoman Omar has frequently used
the anti-semitic language to bash
America's relationship with our number
one ally in the Middle East Israel the
only democracy in the region not long
ago she claimed that our close ties to
the world's only Jewish state all about
the Benjamins and then tweeted once
quote Israel has hypnotized the world
may Allah awaken the people and help
them see the evil doings of Israel and
while the congresswoman frequently uses
shocking language about the country and
our allies she's constantly minimizing
the horrors of terrorism remember during
her time as a state Rep in Minnesota she
asked the judge to grant leniency to
nine men accused of trying to join Isis
yeah those people that cut other
people's heads off murdering terrorists
yeah during a bizarre interview in 2013
she could not even contain her laughter
when talking about al Qaeda Hezbollah
take a look every time the the professor
said al K that he sort of like his
shoulders went up and you know commanded
a al Qaeda you know Hospital experts
and it was you know answer but it is it
is that you don't say America with an
intensity you don't say England with
intensity you know you don't you don't
say the army with an intensity seems
funny to you congresswoman I don't think
there's anything funny about 3,000
Americans killed on 9/11 by al Qaeda or
of course Hezbollah and the terror and
the death and the misery that of course
they are responsible for now
congresswoman Omar also minimized
terrorists during a speech at care you
may remember and keep in mind this is a
fringe Islamic group listed as
unindicted co-conspirators in the Holy
Land Foundation terrorism case take a
look here was founded after 9/11 because
they recognized that some people did
something and that all of us were
starting to lose access to our civil
liberties some people did something
hijack planes ran him into buildings
that fell down hit our Pentagon and a
field in Pennsylvania some things all
more calls Israel evil she accuses even
Obama and Trump of being murderers but
when it comes to 9/11 and al-qaeda just
some people just doing some things
seriously look hard at one of the four
leaders of today's radical extreme
democratic socialist party the people
you see with the most influence on the
twenty twenty Democratic presidential
candidates this should be shocking but
we've seen it coming now each cycle the
Democratic Party lay large further and
further and further to the left and now
there are no more Lieberman scoop
Jackson's moderate Democrats they are a
non-existent part of that party matter
of fact I think they might be literally
gone forever they've been replaced with
socialists who want the government to
control your health care our industries
our businesses our paychecks our lives
our choices they want to be completely
open with borders amnesty for all
unfettered illegal immigration by
the way free healthcare to boot for
illegal immigrants late term abortion
even during birth and in some cases
after birth that would be called murder
and a Fanta side and of course then we
got the green new deal calls for an end
to all oil gas no more planes no more
gas-powered cars and trucks government
forced rehab of every building in
America and of course taxpayer-funded
meals education income and everything
else for people willing and unwilling to
work they don't want to improve this
country they want to remake this country
into something we all know will fail and
tonight they want to impeach the one
person that's been standing in their way
let's take a look I have not made
impeachment central to my election on my
tenure but since the day that I've
gotten elected I've said to people it is
not if he will be impeached but when so
it is time for us to stop allowing this
president to make a mockery out of our
Constitution it's time for us to impeach
this president now if you pay close
attention you know a little bit about
the Constitution she didn't actually
list anything that would be an actual
impeachable offense no surprise there
the radical base of this party does not
care about the will of the American
people the people that voted in Donald
Trump against all odds and with the deep
State against them for them it's about
control 2020 the American people you we
the people you will decide you got to
give up your personal freedoms to a
radical socialist group of Democrats do
you really trust government to take care
of your every need from the minute
you're born to the minute you die
whether you're even unwilling to work or
not anyway they vote to improve the
country okay
preserve their inalienable rights defend
against the greatest country God has
ever given man